So here I am back at my code and I have pasted both the account_sid and the
Authorization Token, into my program. Now the next thing I want to change, is
the body of the text message. I will change it to something I actually want to
send which is, My name is Ron Burgandy?
With a question mark. Now for this 'to' number the commons in the code
suggests that I have to replace it with my
phone number. So, I'm going to select and change
this to my phone number with my country code.
This by the way is also the number I
registered with twilio previously. Then they say the from
number, I have to replace it with my Twilio
number. Now, I remember that Twilio actually gave me
a phone number, but I didn't quite save it.
So, if I go back to my accounts page, and click
on Numbers. I can get my phone number from Twilio. All right,
back to the code and now I can change that number along
with the country code. Next I will save and run my program
and this is the phone that I'm going to receive
the text message. So I'm just going to give my program
a few seconds op, there it is, there's my text
message. Let me read it. You probably can't read it but
it says my name is Ron Burgendy. Alright this just
blows my mind that a few lines of code like this
can help us send a text message. Okay, so now
that this code has worked, let's figure out what's actually going
on with this code.